[Musique]
J'irai tuer le jeu trop tôt alors je lui ai fait
faire cette tâche un autre gars pas
toujours eux client je m'en sors Hinata
il est sous ça tu sais la contrebande
dans le premier film on nous a fait découvrir
le monde des assassins ça  une sorte d'
hyper monde fantastique et dans le chapitre deux,
nous l'ouvrons et nous voyons Laurence
Fishburne jouer le Bowery King,
puis nous entendons parler de cet autre niveau, le
niveau super élevé appelé la table haute
et le type d'action est plus intense
et donne plus de variété  cela implique beaucoup
de judo et de jujitsu et de mélanger cela avec du travail avec des
armes à feu, donc c'était environ trois
mois de judo et de jujitsu et de
travail avec des armes à feu réel, c'est plus sur le
développement mondial et John est plus sur un
code et c'est plus sur un ensemble  d'honneur,
il s'agit davantage des règles qui, encore une fois, sont,
je pense, un grand facteur de motivation et
intéressant est créatif, mais ce n'est peut-
être pas aussi profond et émotionnel qu'un chiot,
donc vous devez prendre l'un pour l'autre, donc
je pense que c'est la principale différence
entre  un et deux autres que deux sont un
peu plus élaborés dans le monde
et il y a probablement quelques
tirs à la tête de plus, donc je suppose que vous avez le
choix, vous voulez une guerre ou voulez-vous
simplement me donner une arme à feu quelqu'un s'il vous plaît obtenez
ceci  homme un pistolet ouais j'ai eu la chance de
travailler avec Laurence Fishburne et Jen
depuis la matrice et c'était vraiment génial
de pouvoir jouer avec lui je pense que dans la
matrice peut-être que nous étions des étudiants mentors et
au chapitre deux, je pense que nous étions plus entre
pairs  vous savez que John Wick va
demander de l'aide au Bowery King mais nous ne
savons pas si le Bowery King va l'
aider ou le tuer et donc je dirais que l'
une des différences fondamentales
l'homme le mythe la légende
John  attends tu n'es pas très doué pour
prendre ta retraite Je travaille sur j'espère que je
peux savoir faire partie du récit du troisième
chapitre j'aimerais voir peut-être John Wick
aller à Jérusalem elle n'appellerait pas ces
mondes et tribus peut-être un désert  scène
j'aimerais voir John Wick se faire empoisonner
et avoir c  des hallucinations folles et
comme et peut-être qu'il y a une scène dans le
désert quelque part, je pense que cela ferait une
excellente émission de télévision, en particulier les préquelles
de tout cela, on en parle, je pense que le
studio essaie de développer cela de manière créative
et de voir si c'est quelque chose de viable
ce serait bien mais ce serait très
intéressant d'être gracié à coup sûr dans
le monde de John wick tu sais parce que
tu as tout ce monde souterrain le monde
de la table haute continentale Maori King
je pense que ça se prête à la télévision dans
le sens où  il y a tellement de
personnages et de mondes dans lesquels vous pouvez entrer, donc je
pense que je pense évidemment qu'il doit être bien
écrit et bien exécuté et je ne sais pas
si John Wick apparaîtra dans ce
monde dans l'émission de télévision mais nous vous
verrons